okay do you watch angry video game nerd
uh i
every now and then i do i like because i
kind of grew up watching
fgn and like uh i i like going back
because like all of his old stuff is
on youtube no yeah i know i know i love
it so like i love going back and
watching like the spider-man episode
like that's still my favorite one i
think it's just nice
in youtube i think where the platform is
just constantly changing everything's
changing yeah it's just
nice having an anchor like angry video
game nerd yeah
it's just a constant right like you know
whether i enjoy the content you know it
depends on the video right but yeah it's
just nice having a creator who's
consistent no drama
yeah just constantly makes bangers like
oh he's [ __ ] i think recently he made
an earthbound video which was fun that
was such a good video
it was like last year i think but it was
really good every so often i go back and
see like the parallels between what
happened to angry video game nerd and
what happened to nostalgia critic
right you know what i'm crazy yeah it's
it's it's oh my god
oh my god it's it's it's so jarring
to see the evolution or the
[ __ ] media critic reviewers yeah just
seeing like angry video game nerd being
the anchor
and then whatever the [ __ ] happened in
the nostalgia critic did you see his
game show
no i didn't yeah he did a game show he
funded it like via crowdfunding
right a channel called um uh ralph the
movie maker
yeah that is he does really good movie
reviews really funny guy i really like
gordon ramsey-esque like just really
brutal really funny don't agree with
this takes always but yeah really good
really fun good channel but he did a
video about the nostalgia critics game
show
and it is bad like it looks like a
school project
and they spent like they spent like i
think like 50 thousand dollars on it
right
and it's it's garbage like
have you like remember that period in
like youtube reviewers
where they had to have like a [ __ ]
story behind it behind their reviews
do you remember that period yes where it
was like channel awesome they should do
two hour reviews do you remember that
and like the first 30 minutes was like a
garbage skit yeah
yeah whereas abcn was like i can do that
but condense it into like 15 minutes
max i think because it's also mega
cheesy whereas like i think nostalgia
critic is
they're like the same thing right yeah
the same quality but almost i mean
that's kind of insulting
yeah but they're kind of the same thing
where they're like cheesy
obviously like very tongue-in-cheek no
tongue and cheese you're playing a
character
but obviously the two wanted to be
seen differently yeah that sounds great
want to be seen as like mega
professional yeah angry video game noted
he's happy
like it's tongue and cheek it's camp
yeah exactly and that's so endearing
where is seeing nostalgia credit try to
be like
you know what's the [ __ ] movie he
made that's like the holy grail or
something that was like two hours long
it was terrible
it was i swear like nostalgia critic has
done so many [ __ ] side projects that
have just ended up being absolutely [ __ ]
like he made yeah
he made uh he made a [ __ ] parody
album
of pink floyd that was oh oh my god i
remember that
and i someone who's like the wall is
like one of my favorite [ __ ] albums
yeah it's like it's an album that's
adored by everybody the movie is
[ __ ] amazing and then i listened to
that album i got like two songs in i'm
just like i can't but then i watch
[ __ ] needle drops yeah
absolutely destroying it and i'm like
yes
this is why i love you anthony yeah so
[ __ ] because it was just
it was just seeing a creator just trying
to do something that was so
unnecessary yeah you know what i mean
like it's it's like like you said it was
it was someone who obviously wanted to
be respected
right and be seen as like someone who
did something great
but it was just so like
how can i how can i do how can i word
this if you self-indulgent yeah it was
very self-indulgent you know
like and it's like and it was extra like
cringy as well just like seeing that
like he was clearly trying to be like
funny and edgy about it being like i'm
gonna trash all over this album that
everybody loves i'm like yeah
not everyone likes this album yeah like
just chill out like the nostalgia critic
is a
og youtube channel that reviewed movies
by the way
by the way yeah i'm assuming that
everyone who's listening to this episode
yeah
it's gives someone [ __ ] never mind about
him watch needle drop he's great
i [ __ ] love him yeah i like anthony
container yeah using new york times as
well recently that's cool
oh yeah i don't i almost never agree
with his opinions but [ __ ] hell that
guy
can but that's the thing i like about
critics uh
the good ones on youtube is that like i
don't have to agree with them but like
damn they're entertaining yeah
their input is still interesting right
yeah yeah i think like there's a lot of
movie channels like that like uh
your movie sucks the hog yeah yeah yeah
i like his channel a lot he did a really
good video on like the lion king
and kimber comparison two hours [ __ ]
long yeah
it's a really [ __ ] good video i
really like his channel uh i mean
obviously don't agree with all the
opinions
there's also probably one of my favorite
movie critic guys is uh this guy called
spooky rice
oh i showed you that right no yeah i
think you and aki were like super into
it yes i showed aki because i wanted to
like because he he reviewed like
all the whole like the like horrible
like worst horror disgusting
movies right he manages to be able to
sit through it enough times that he can
write a comprehensive review about it
but you just none of it comes in because
he shows it as well
when it happens but like imagine that
youtuber ukulele music that kind of
personality reviewing like a horror
thing like
yes so then he he ate the [ __ ] and it's
like
why are you saying it like i didn't
really like that scene though yeah
i [ __ ] love his wall his intro which
is uh like
no he's like cue the gohan and then and
then he's like has a logo and then
[ __ ] creepy gohan just like shows up
i'm like
there's no there's nothing he just likes
gohan i guess i'm like alright i respect
that